do you remember what inspired you to
follow your passion now I've always
loved to create but I remember I got
into 3D art and was immediately inspired
by the thought if I can think it I can
create it if I knew how to use the
programs then technically I'm only
limited by my imagination and that
thought still has me inspired today so
in this video I want to break down my
process for my latest piece of 3D art in
the hopes of inspiring people who want
to learn about the wonderful world of 3D
art I'm going to cover a ton of topics
tips and tricks so there's lots to take
away and I'll be using a free program
called Unreal Engine so feel free to
follow along or just sit back relax and
enjoy the process
the challenge for this piece of art
robots create is twofold first we want
to create a photorealistic environment
in Unreal Engine 5 Second is to do it in
20 days because last time I made art for
my challenge I overestimated the actual
days available and underestimated the
actual work needed which resulted in a
soul-crushing creative process using
mid-journey an AI art generator I
imagined an empty white stage and in the
middle an old man tapped into virtual
reality but I didn't want to just create
a blank white virtual screen so I
gathered more references of grungy
warehouses and compiled them in a mood
board program called puref using
reference imagery is a great way to
create unique art quickly even Kim
jong-ji the late great pen and Ink
Master who drew massive murals from
memory would go back to reference if he
didn't know what the object looked like
but now that we have a direction to
create in it's time to start building
starting with our warehouse
since I only have 20 days to create I
want to get a version of my environment
as quickly as possible that way we can
tweak the light texture and composition
before adding details inside of Unreal
Engine 5 I'm using wall assets that come
with the starter content to block out my
warehouse I'll create a cine camera
actor from the place actors window and
right click it in the outliner to Pilot
the camera once inside I'll adjust the
aspect ratio to 237 for a widescreen
look and finally for scale I'll import a
human figure which will replace with our
custom character later but here we can
line up our camera make any adjustments
to our walls consult our reference and
scour quixel Mega scans for a
warehouse-like objects qixel comes free
with Unreal Engine 5 and houses a
massive asset Library full of textures
and 3D scans now one of the best things
about unreal is we can block out our
scene with these full quality Assets in
real time again my goal here is to shape
the light composition camera angle and
texture without getting into the
nitty-gritty I want to get to 80
completion in 20 of the time so we can
spend eighty percent of our time working
the last twenty percent of the details
finally I'll add a post-process volume
making sure to set infinite extent to
Unbound and tweak the brightness and
saturation attached to lock in our look
and with my warehouse blocked out the
overhead lighting sketched in a floor
and wall texture in place and my camera
move locked in it's time to move on to
the details that bring our scene to life
I'll start with some scaffolding that'll
hold the screen array that builds up
this virtual room I'm just building it
from default cylinders and unreal by
piecing together one chunk grouping it
and duplicating that piece around the
main VR room let's add some detail to
our TV screens so I was at breakfast one
morning and saw this TV mounted on the
wall and the mount itself was the
perfect reference so I modeled a rough
likeness in Cinema 4D imported it into
unreal and populated my scene with it
one quick tip for you guys if you're
importing objects into unreal and the
little preview box doesn't look right
you can toggle thumbnail edit mode and
left click and drag to rotate the
preview image it's super handy for
keeping tabs on what you got in your
content browser and this is actually a
good time to talk about organization
because it's already getting out of hand
with all these duplicates usually I have
a lighting folder a geometry folder in a
camera folder for this scene the
geometry folder is going to be the most
maxed out so try to break down your
scene into chunks with appropriately
named folders to stay organized it'll be
you guys out in the long run when you're
trying to show and hide certain objects
now let's work on building a detailed
ceiling first I want to justify our
overhead lighting with some rusted
fluorescent lamps luckily Mega scans has
us covered on the housing itself I'll
use a few cylinders from the place
actor's window to act as the fluorescent
tubes and apply an emissive material
instance to them just add some metal
rods to mount them to the ceiling select
everything with Ctrl G to group now you
can easily duplicate it across your
scene and now that we have our lights in
place let's add some water pipes on the
ceiling I built out a basic pipe
structure from three simple pieces
grouped them and went to duplicating
I'll place them in a grid pattern on the
ceiling here and add a bit of
crookedness to them it'll help avoid the
mechanical 3D look I'll Trail them down
the main support pillars terminating
into a couple electrical boxes and I
want to add one last sealing detail so
inside of Cinema 4D I'll make a huge
plane subdivide it select the points I
want to lock in place give it a cloth
tag set them as fit fixed points and hit
play then bake the object down on a
frame you're happy with import it into
unreal and drop it in sweet are ceilings
looking pretty believable now let's move
on to the ground floor details I'll grab
some cracked concrete and leakage decals
from qixel and slap them on to the main
pillars here decals can be used in
unreal to add a bunch of detail and
texture to your scene for cheap qixel
artist Victor Omen transformed his scene
from this to this using only decals and
Lighting in his Silent Hill bathroom
tutorial another great way to add detail
is with cables and wires lots of them
and I'm adding these in three different
ways first of which is by hand in Cinema
4D using splines if you draw a spline
spawn a circle spline scale it down to a
reasonable size and place them both in a
sweep object you can get a pretty fast
cable setup I'm using the exact same
setup for the wire bundles I'm using a
handful of circle splines stretched out
and moved around for variation I'll
import both of these into unreal and
place them all around my scaffolding for
added detail but I'd love a series of
wires coming out from the bottom of our
VR room as well because I'm hand drawing
one set in cinema duplicating it and
adding a bit of variation I should have
similar related this so we'll get into
that in just a second but they look
great in our scene I'll just slap these
cable covers on top duplicate the whole
thing and give our foreground a nice bit
of detail at the top of the shot it's
still looking a bit empty though so
we're going to utilize the epic games
marketplace now if you're not taking
advantage of the free stuff epic gives
out every month you're definitely
missing out so in the unreal section of
the epic games launcher under
Marketplace you can search for free for
the month where you'll find five free
assets every single month if you click
add to project all these assets that
make up the demo scene will be available
in your content browser my goal is to
fill out the corners of this Warehouse
so I'll start with a handful of
electrical boxes along the back wall and
a huge generator to block the back
corner next I want to add a little
command station off to the left here
where a technician could operate this VR
stage from a computer oh and a little
friend of course because you know this
computer ain't running itself let's put
an industrial push cart off to the right
with a chunky generator on top maybe a
little toolbox next to it too now
another push card off to the side here
behind a pile of covered support beams
looks nice but oh my goodness what if
there's a fire better put this here just
in case now I've placed everything on
with the intention of drawing the eye to
our VR stage which we'll detail out in a
second but I want to do one more thing
and that's to connect some more wires to
this generator and run them off to the
right so eyeballing the inputs I
generated a few more of those spline
based cables gave them a rope Dynamics
tag made a plane with a collider tag on
it to act as the floor and hit play
awesome but I want the wires to look
tossed around and messy so I'll animate
two large cylinders give them collider
tags and bump these wires around just a
bit perfect I'll bake it down and drop
them into my scene for the VR stage I
used mid Journey again to generate
ghibli-esque watercolor Landscapes as
the backdrop but I wanted there to be
some movement in what I'd imagine to be
like a loading screen or something so I
use trap code particular a particle
system made by red giant for after
effects to simulate falling leaves and
parented a low-res Sakura Sprite to each
particle finally I added the CC Ball
action effect to make things look a bit
more pixelated and added a grid layer on
top to cheat a video screen array I
saved each individual wall as a JPEG
sequence and set them up as an animated
emissive material in Unreal Engine which
if you want to figure out how to do that
I cover it in this video here so take a
look later but now that we got what I
think is a pretty sweet environment
there is one part of me that feels like
something is missing this would honestly
be a great time to send your art to a
trusted friend and take a break from
your scene for a while while you wait
for feedback it's super important to
take your eyes off of what you've been
invested in for the last week and get a
different perspective because you can
unlock some cool stuff you never thought
of since my good buddy Adam was working
on the music for the top 100 Montage
that this render was for I sent it to
him a day later he got back and was like
dude that's so sick how this setup is
outside I was like bud what are you
talking about let me resend the file I
must have sent the wrong one he said not
Chief I love the early morning light
behind the overpass with the building
silhouetted on the horizon
cam I'm just a bit confused with what
you're seeing right now but you know
what I'm gonna make it happen because
honestly I was looking for a way to
incorporate an outdoor element to my
scene somehow the planets aligned Adam
saw the light and now I have a great New
Angle that'll make my scene even cooler
don't get hooked on idea number one be
open to your art morphing into different
iterations of itself chances are the V3
is going to be cooler than the V1 and if
you're so dead set on what you set out
to create in the first place you may
miss this opportunity but let's dive
back in and take this scene to the next
level by modeling some Warehouse windows
in c4d using reference of course after
some slight redecorating and unreal I
distributed them appropriately as far as
my outdoor lighting setup is concerned I
used to use the built-in directional
light Skylight atmospheric light
atmospheric height fog et cetera Etc but
boy was I chomping it up big time
because I did not know about Ultra
Dynamic Sky which allows me to have full
control over the look of my sky and even
add weather all inside of one easy to
use objects so I'll tweak my settings
until I get that pre-dawn look I'll make
the Stars pop just enough and add some
slight atmospheric fog to really lock
the vibe in but something's missing I
want to add a ton of buildings to the
skyline to make it feel like we're on
the outskirts of a city and my number
one go-to resource for large-scale
buildings is hands down kit bash 3D I've
been using their stuff for years now and
I'm happy to say that they are the
perfect sponsor for today's video kit
bash 3D creates the highest quality
themed 3D kits on the market each themed
kit comes with a total of 100 plus
buildings props and assets making
digital World building an absolute Joy
they have a massive selection of kits
too when it comes to cityscapes for my
particular scene ones like Neo Shanghai
New York City Los Angeles Neo Tokyo
Goliath or sci-fi industrial would be
perfect but they cover everything from
spaceships Dark Fantasy and Elysium to
DMZ diesel Punk cyber district and a ton
more all their kits come expertly
textured with Native file formats for
unreal blender c4d and all the other
major software and render combos so if
you want to grab one of these kits for
yourself kit bash 3D is offering you
guys 20 off at checkout by using the
code punisher20 but they're also giving
out a free full scale kit during their
brand new mission to Minerva 3D
challenge that is running right now
they're challenging artists to build out
their dream settlement using the new kit
each artist laying a brick to populate
the Galaxy together which honestly
sounds pretty freaking sweet so if you
want to challenge yourself click that
link in the description download your
free full scale kit and use the code
punisher20 to get 20 off any kit you
want links in the description go get it
now let me show you how easy it is to
build out this cityscape once you drop
the kit into your Unreal Engine content
structure they'll be available in your
content browser here and if we dive into
the blueprints folder we can browse the
different types of buildings it's just a
matter of building out little chunks of
buildings duplicating them and placing
them appropriately now I'm digging the
placement here but I want a handful of
Apartments to be lit up because the
city's not abandoned it's just super
early in the morning we're gonna build
out an easy custom cityscape emissive
texture so let me show you how next time
you're in San Diego California aboard
the Midway aircraft carrier at night
Point your camera at some buildings snap
a picture of the cityscape bring it into
Photoshop align the Dank thing crush the
black levels boost the highlights clean
it up a little bit and import that PNG
into the kit bash Glass Master material
or you can just download the one that I
made for free on my patreon it's up
there just go grab it and it's kind of
as easy as plugging the image straight
into the emission slot but we want to
control its size and intensity and it
would be nice to toggle our custom
lights with a checkbox in our material
instance as well so starting with
intensity I'll hold M and left click to
make a multiply node and hold s and left
click for a scalar parameter set to 1 as
default crank this number to make our
lights brighter for control over the
scale of this image we can actually
search for a material function called MF
underscore tiling which is the Mega
scans tiling material function just pipe
it into the UV slot into our texture and
we're good for now and to make our
custom lights toggleable I'll right
click and search for a switch parameter
pipe our custom setup into true and kit
bash is set up into false making sure to
set the switcher default to unchecked
let's save and close and if we open the
kit bash glass material instance we can
toggle our custom City Light Mission and
adjust the settings we just set up on
the fly now this might sound obvious but
I try and tweak these settings from my
actual camera angle because at the end
of the day it's the only angle we're
really seeing everything from while
we're on the topic of custom materials
let's get some smudges and raindrops on
these windows and set up a fully
customizable service and Perfection
Master material it'll give you full
control over all the surface
imperfections the grunge the grime the
fingerprints the smudges that you want
to add to any material now it took me a
minute to understand but it's actually
pretty simple in the end for the
textures I'll be using my Surface
imperfection pack that I put together in
this video here where I walk you through
how I hand made these bad boys the pack
is on my patreon along with all my other
assets but these textures are also
available on my gumroad and for people
who made it this far in the video I got
you all covered the first 50 people to
use the code let me get them textures
half off I got you I will start in my
Glass Master material I'm going to drag
in a smudge texture and plug it into the
roughness slot by default it's looking
nice but how do we control how rough or
how intense the smudges are or how rough
the parts that aren't smudged are well
that's what a linear interpolate note is
for or alert node it's identical to a
mixed node an octane or a mix RGB node
in blender you just hold L and left
click to make one plug the texture into
Alpha and the lerp into roughness and we
should have the same result as before
now we want to make a couple scalar
parameters by holding s and left
clicking the first we'll call roughness
Min and the other roughness Max the
order here is important by default we
can leave roughness Min at zero but with
a Max of one and we'll set roughness Max
to one by default also with a Max of one
next I want to control the intensity of
the texture itself so we can hold M and
left click for a multiply node that will
sneak in between the texture and the
lerp and create another scalar parameter
by holding s and left clicking set to
one by default we can crank this up to
push its intensity next I want to
control its scale and rotation too so
I'll drag the textures UV option out and
search for that MF underscore tiling
function again finally I want to be able
to just toggle this surface imperfection
setup we just made because maybe we
don't need it with every single material
we use I'll drag out our setup into a
switch parameter named surface
imperfection into true and a basic
scalar parameter called roughness into
false by default we'll make sure the
switcher is set to unchecked and finally
let's make sure all of these adjustable
nodes are grouped properly so I'll
select them all and make sure they're in
a group called roughness and be sure to
right click the texture and convert it
to a parameter as well so you can easily
switch out the imperfection for any one
you want select all this hit C to group
it save right click our Master material
and let's create immaterial instance
once inside we can see our toggle for
surface imperfection which unlocks the
min max roughness intensity as well as
the texture itself and its UV controls
and feel free to switch out that surface
imperfection for anything you want
and with all of that we finally have our
complete environment but I still want to
show you what I'm doing to take the art
to the max after it's rendered I want to
talk about my render settings in Unreal
Engine and briefly touch on my character
setup I look I love making environments
but I am not a character artist or an
animator but I did manage to learn about
Daz a free and powerful character
generator that lets you adjust every
possible facet of your character it's
got a huge Marketplace for clothes and
accessories and it'll let you post them
however you'd like Daz has plugins for
most software so I imported my character
into c4d and used their Auto ik rig
setup to hand animate this dude yes I
said hand animate once animated I was
able to simulate the pants though using
c4d's new cloth tools it was a tedious
trial and error process to get things
right shout outs to Joel and my Discord
for helping me figure it out but I
finally baked it down imported it in
unreal and got things running in
sequencer unreal's non-linear editor but
what do you do when your art is complete
you go to render and your program
crashes time and time again it crashes
and at this rate it doesn't look like
you're going to make your deadline that
exact thing happened to me this time
around but here's how I went about
solving it so I started making a list of
renders and settings that I had already
done and I reduced my settings until I
could complete a render from start to
finish then slowly started raising my
settings recording all of this in my
render log if something crashed three
times in a row I'd move on to the next
test until I found the sweet spot for my
scene but what if this doesn't work what
if your project file is just cursed well
in that case it's probably cursed you
need to start a brand new project file
and copy paste everything over you
probably just unknowingly toggled some
deep setting never to be found ever
again this happens sometimes and can be
quite common if you're new to the
program as far as render settings go
I'll link you to my last Unreal Engine
video where I go over all that stuff and
the only other thing I did differently
on export this time was export in the
aces color space which allows you to
extract and maintain a lot more color
and value data from your image our boy
William Foshay has got you covered on
that end so go check that out but with
my final render from Unreal Engine
there's one last thing I'm going to do
to spice things up it's a super
important step not to be missed and that
is adding post effects it brings your
render from Simply a 3D render to
something that was physically shot with
a camera and when you're going for
photorealism it's kind of crucial so
first I'll color correct my scene in a
free program called DaVinci Resolve it's
a node-based system so with my first
node I'll tweak the contrast only making
sure I retain Shadow and highlight
detail I'm a sucker for vignette and I
want to make sure the highlights from my
sky outside side aren't affected by my
vignette though my next node will be for
color adjustments only and already this
is looking much better and three last
things that I want to do to bring this
render to the max is add some Bloom
which really emulates like certain
coatings on lenses as well as film grain
which gives your entire image a really
subtle realistic texture we're all used
to seeing on cameras these days and
finally Barrel Distortion which if
you're a fan of Ian Hubert you already
know it's the fisheye effect just
remember subtlety is key here
after 20 days of work on a 45 second
shot we have our final render
foreign I hope you guys enjoyed this I
hope you learned something and I hope
you all stay inspired to follow your
creative passions subscribe for more art
breakdowns environment art live streams
and 3D challenges in the near future my
name is Clinton Jones and I'll catch you
all soon peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]